Could you hazard a guess when you're up
is clamping down on speech critical of
Islam when you slam is causing
lots of problems with rape,
gangs,
terrorism,
and generally being a menace?
Why?
Well,
I suppose if there's,
um,
let's say if I was going
to oppose that statement,
I would say,
well perhaps it's a propagandistic,
uh,
what would you call it,
conspiracy to blame what's happening
in Europe on Islamic immigrants?
I guess part of the problem is,
is that,
at least as far as I can tell,
the news has become
sufficiently unreliable because
it's so polarized that we
can't really tell what's going on.
I mean,
I think the reason that Europe is clamping
down on speech critical of Islam is
partly the same reason that the entire
Western world is clamping down on speech.
That's critical of anything that
is associated with group identity,
which is pretty much any set
of ideas that unites people.
And it's,
it's a consequence of the collective
decision that we've made that
egalitarianism and,
uh,
conflict avoidance constitute the two
highest virtues and they Trump everything
else including free speech.
Now why that's happened?
It's very,
very difficult thing to say.
I mean,
um,
I suspect to some degree that it's a
consequence of women becoming involved in
the political system,
which is something that we've never
experienced before and women are more
agreeable
by nature then man and,
and variable people are,
are compassionate towards those,
they see a suffering and that
seems to include any minority,
especially when you combine that with
the kind of neo Marxist doctrine,
the claims that anyone who
has an advantage swiped it.
And I think in the Islamic situation
you'd get a real conflict there because
it's obviously the case that many Islamic
practices are not commensurate with
postmodern neo Marxist feminism let's say.
But they seem to get a free pass.
And I guess that's because the idea
that all cultures are equal trumps the
requirement for human rights for women.
And,
and maybe the other thing that's even
darker is that there's a fair bit of
revolutionary fervor in the more radical
end of the left political spectrum.
And that radical server is devoted
towards tearing down the patriarchy.
And of course that's basically
Western civilization.
And so if,
because Islam isn't part
of Western civilization,
then it can be seen as an ally in that,
in that attempt.
Um,
that's what it looks like to me.
I also think,
you know,
that ignorance and,
and all of that contribute,
it isn't obvious that people who
are afraid of such things as Islamophobia
really understand anything about
Islam.
I wouldn't say I understand
anything about Islam,
even though I've read a fair bit about it,
it's very difficult to put yourself
inside a different belief system.
I'm somewhat apprehensive about Islam
because it looks to me like it's a
totalizing system as well as a religion
and it's a totalizing system because
everything has to come under its purview,
including law and,
and,
um,
everything that goes along with that.
There's no separation
between church and state.
And so I don't see how that's commensurate
with a western moment of existence.
And I don't think people want to have
that conversation because they want to
say,
well,
no,
everyone diverse as they are.
And important as that diversity is
apparently such that everyone has to be
represented equally.
The diversity isn't really of anything
about anything fundamental and we can all
get along without a problem.
And,
um,
I'm afraid that that's
extraordinarily naive.
And then I suppose there's also an
element of something like Western guilt,
I guess perhaps for what has been
described as our imperialists past.
Um,
the,
there's been a very longterm assault
on,
on the,
what would you call moral
on the morality of the West.
We're often viewed as the rapers
and pillagers of the world.
And that sort of goes along
with the environmentalist ethos.
And so I think we do have a
fair bit of guilt about that,
whether it's warranted or not.
Um,
I mean,
history is a bloody nightmare and
it doesn't matter where you look.
And I would say at least the West
has brought advantages along with its
disadvantages.
Um,
and I think that our attitude towards
individuality is fundamentally correct and
absolutely vital.
And I would also say that
the only countries in the
world that are essentially
worth living in,
in any real sense are the ones that
are predicated on the Judeo Christian
tradition and manifested in
western the western body of laws.
So,
but there's still plenty of guilt
and there's plenty of people who,
well,
who are,
what contemptuous of being as we
discussed in the last question,
and also angry with the political system
because they're powerless or maybe
they'd been hurt by
male authority figures.
Um,
and that happens very frequently.
And so they have absolutely no trust
in higher in hierarchical structures.
And there you might add to that to certain
amount of laziness because the thing
about hierarchical structures is
that they impose values on people.
And then in order to progress in
that value structure that you have to
discipline yourself and work hard,
and many of the radical leftists happened
to be very low in conscientiousness.
And so they don't in hard work and they
don't believe that people get to where
they're going by hard work.
And then,
well,
one other thing,
there's a group of people I think who
are basically personality disordered.
And those are the ones that have never
had a positive relationship with anything
that was masculine.
And so whenever they see anything
masculine that has motive power,
and that would include
authority and competence,
not just power,
they assume that that's tyrannical.
And it's part of the postmodern
assumption that all power higher,
all hierarchies are hierarchies of power.
When the truth of the matter is,
is that hierarchies in the West are
usually hierarchies of authority and
competence.
And they're like,
they're oriented towards getting a
certain task done and they actually do get
the task done,
but were dubious about our own ethical.
Um,
what would you say?
Integrity.
And I guess that's also why it's a
particular importance for people to try to
act on asleep.
Because if you don't act honestly,
and then you start to doubt your own
integrity and then when people come after
you,
you're going to be weak.
And that's a really bad idea.